Hey.
I wanted to give you guys a few
tips on how you can become
more of a console power-user.
If you are not familiar
with console.log, this
video is not for you.
All right.
First we're going to
get right into it.
You'll notice that I'm here
inside of jsFiddle.
It's just listing out exactly
what I'm going to be talking
about right now.
And, well, we do have a
little bit of script.
Over here, we've got a little
Ajax request that's going to
fire off whenever I
click on the page.
So we're going to fire that
Ajax request, and when it
comes back, we're going to
create a text area, add that
to the DOM, and then set the
value of the text area to be
whatever came back from
the Ajax request.
Now, I'm going to do that here,
and I click, and then
text areas come in.
That's good.
But sometimes you'll be doing
this, and you'll expect this
to show up in the console.
And by default, it
doesn't show up
in the Chrome DevTools.
You can right click and
turn on XHR logging.
And so now, when I have that on,
all those XHRs are logged
to the console, and I can go
over to Network and figure out
exactly the details
of those requests.
Now you might have noticed,
Preserve Log is here.
This is brand new.
So on page refreshes, your
console can stay preserved,
which is pretty cool.
So I'm going to go ahead and--
I think I'll keep this on.
And I'm going to show
you console.time.
So I type console.time up
here, and we're going
to give it a name.
And I need to say
when it ends.
And so console.time and timeEnd
is just a nice way for
you to kind of measure how
long something takes.
Now, you could do it yourself
with the data object, but we
have a little hook for it.
So I'm going to click, and so
now we have an idea of how
long it takes from the
start of the Ajax to
the end of the Ajax.
It's pretty cool.
Console.dir is an
interesting one.
And to do it, I'm going
to dir out the text
area that I've created.
And I want to show that in
comparison to console.log.
So we'll both log and
dir that out.
I'll run that, and
now I'll click.
So here we have--
this is the log view, and this
is more of like the tree-level
view, and console.dir gives you
more of the DOM-level view
of an object.
So sometimes you kind
of want that.
Now, I'm going to take this app
and blow this up into the
full-screen view.
And I will point out that if
you're actually typing in the
console, you could type
console.dir and do that right
inside the console, but you
can have a nice little
convenience function, so you
can just type dir directly,
and that works as well.
So there's a few other
methods that are
available inside the console.
So one of them is Inspect,
and so this is cool.
So I have this text area, and I
want to actually go see that
in the Elements tab.
And I can just type inspect.
We hop right over to Elements,
and it's already selected.
Now similarly, I might have
an element that--
I'm seeing an element, so I
actually want to access it in
the script.
So I access it right here.
I click on that, and I'm going
to bring up Console with the
Escape key.
And $0.
And so that just is
a reference to
whatever was selected.
And so this just works normally,
so I can kind of do
whatever I want with it.
Another one, and this
is fun, is $$.
And so this is also known as
the bling bling function.
Bling bling is pretty cool.
So this is just a peek into
the DevTool source.
It's just a wraparound query
selector all, and so I can
just pass a selector to it and
see what matches on the page.
So here, I have two text areas
on the page, and so that's
what it returns.
It's easy as that.
Now, monitorEvents.
I'm going to show monitorEvents
to you.
And it does what it says
on the [? TIM. ?]
And monitorEvents.
And I'm going to pass at one
of these text areas.
And there we go.
Now, it's this text
area, here.
OK, cool.
So all the MouseEvents--
you see mousemove, click,
KeyboardEvents, scroll events--
I get to see all the events
that are firing on this
object, which gives you a lot
insight into what's going on.
Now, there is another way to do
this, in that I can do the
same thing, and I can pass at
a second primer of either
mouse or key.
And now, with key, I only
get the keyboard events.
No scroll, no mouse events.
So that's pretty cool.
Next, I want to show you
keys and values.
So keys gives you the names of
the keys [? in the ?] object,
all the properties
and the methods.
So I'm just going to
pass the document--
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
document.head, document.node
type.
There's a lot of
stuff on there.
Similarly, values gives me
back all the values.
There's a lot of different kinds
of values, a bunch of
functions, stuff like that.
I'm going to go back to keys for
a second, and there's some
pretty cool stuff in here-- a
web visibility state, some
interesting stuff.
And I'd love to dig into
this a little bit more.
So I could copy-paste this,
but it's little awkward.
The easier way is just to call
the copy method that's built
right into the console.
This copies it to your clipboard
immediately.
So I can go over to my text
editor, paste it, and do
whatever I need to do to it.
Oops.
No, no.
There we go.
That's what I wanted.
All right, cool.
Now, I just want to show two
pretty cool techniques coming
from some other browsers.
First I'm going to head
over to Opera.
This is opera.next.
And we have up HTML5 Rocks, and
sometimes you just want
jQuery to work with.
On this page, we actually
don't have jQuery.
On Opera, I can type double
slash, and call jQuery as a
function, and it just
loads in jQuery.
It's like the jQuery
[? a.size ?]
bookmarklet.
And now I can use jQuery
to my heart's content.
That's pretty cool.
Pretty cool feature in Opera.
Switch over to Firefox Aurora.
And here we have a page
that has an iframe.
All right?
I'm going to open
up this iframe.
Look at the DOM view, and
you'll see the iframe.
Inside of that is a script,
and inside of
that script is a secret.
So this is a common thing.
You'll have a script inside.
You'll want to understand what's
going on inside that
script, but of course, your
console is operating inside
the context of the outside
frame, right?
And so, I'm asking what
the secret is, and
it's not out here.
It's inside there.
So in Firebug, you can
type "cd." And
cd changes the context.
And so, I'm actually going to
go and select that frame.
There's that frame.
And now I need to pass the
window object, so I'm going to
pass that content window, and
it looks about right.
And, cool.
So we actually just changed the
context of what Firebug is
looking at, and now I can type
secret, get my answer.
So I'm querying the Javascript
that's going on inside of
here, and to return back to the
outer context, I just do
cd(top), and I'm back
where I started.
That's about it.
All right, so I would definitely
recommend checking
out the DevTools website, where
there's a bunch more
docs on all this stuff, if
you're interested in digging
and learning more.
All right, thanks.